[Music]
children's and cartoon films are not
always so exciting for the adult viewer
granted there are still classics from
childhood that you watch nostalgically
in the evening on the couch
every now and then the makers allow
themselves a joke or two in the movies
which was either meant for the parents
or for
us to burst out laughing when we finally
got it 10 years later
so to help you pick the next kids movie
or to narrow down the next movie night
today we have 10 hidden moments in
family and animated movies
that only grownups understand
it took three whole movies before
aladdin and the beautiful jasmine
finally made it to the altar but even
then not everything goes according to
plan
during the ceremony they are attacked by
the 40 thieves
the elephant stumping makes the waltz
tremble where pongini says
i thought the earth wasn't supposed to
move until the honeymoon
a joke that we certainly didn't
understand as children 1996
but laugh about all the more today
in toy story 2 we get to see the cute
cowgirl jesse for the first time
and one guy is particularly fond of the
red haired lady
our favorite space ranger buzz lightyear
he not only shows her this during a hot
cell sedans
but also in another scene once jesse
opens the door for the dog in a clever
stunt
his flip-out wings soar upwards a scene
that the entire male world will
understand but certainly not the kids in
the cinema
[Music]
101 dalmatians not only exist as a
popular animated film
as of 1996 the white and black spotted
furry friends even got one of the best
live
action film adaptions when cruella de
vil goes to anita and roger's home she
learns that they're expecting a child
consistent with their litter of 101
dalmatians
this prompts the villainous to first
look at roger than at the docks and say
puppies you've been a busy boy whether
this was some kind of allusion to anita
other four-legged friends is something
nobody wants to know and we'd rather
not answer it as youngsters we'd not yet
understood this joke for sure
not for nothing did inside out win the
oscar for best animated film in 2016.
the film is about young riley who has to
move with her parents from her perfect
home to san francisco
to illustrate how this affects raleigh's
psyche the creators transform her
emotions into the characters of disgust
joy sadness anger and fear these led by
joy
take turns controlling the young girl's
actions when
riley lies in bed for the first time in
her new home fear takes control and
talks about there being bears in town
fury's response to this is that while
there are no bears in the city
he is seen a human as areas one bear in
the lgbtq community describes the
external characteristics of a certain
type of man namely big and harry
and if you take into account what role
the city plays for the whole community
it's a more than clear reference
right after the movie came out there
were already many fan theories and
newspaper articles about whether riley
herself belongs to the lgbtq community
the disney movie cars has managed to do
what many didn't believe was possible
that cars can be given emotions that are
also very well conveyed to the audience
in short you can empathize with the cars
but also in this children's movie one or
two jokes and situations have been
included which make
especially the parents smile in one
scene you see a car driving past a
servicing area
on the exit sign it says top down truck
stop all
convertible waitresses so this
particular establishment has
topless waitresses a joke that i'm sure
most grown-ups must have smiled at
frozen is a movie that has become an
indispensable part of
every living room elsa christoph swan
and olaf not only make
children laugh and cheer but also adults
as in most disney classics however
the creators have allowed themselves one
or two puns that you certainly didn't
understand as a child
in the first part released in 2013 the
grouchy iceman christoph helps princess
anna find her sister
on his sleigh he asked the young
princess about her fiance hunt so as to
prove to her that she knows him far too
badly to be engaged to him when asked
what shoe size he is she merely answers
rolling her eyes foot size doesn't
matter
whether foot size is important or not is
something you can discuss
in the comments the australian animated
film happy feat from 2006 is truly a
film for young and old
the plot around the penguin mumble is
beautifully presented and touches
all hearts in one scene however you get
to look twice as an adult to make sure
that you don't see exactly
what's going on in your mind in the
scene when mumble slides across the eyes
with this penguin partner and they have
a little race
it often looks like they're doing other
things
not only are they portraying different
dwell positions in the clip but if you
leave out the video editing and listen
to the audio it sounds more like pillow
talk as opposed to a children's movie
the halloween movie hocus pocus which
was released in used theaters in 1993
started slow before it became the
beloved cult classic it is today
the movie is about three witch sisters
who were called back to earth on
halloween and now try to proposing to
get
eternal youth to achieve this they need
only two things
the souls of children and a very old
witch book
as a bus pulls up in front of them they
wonder what kind of transportation it is
the driver answers that this is a
vehicle that tries to grant them their
desires
they say that they need children to
which the bus driver replies that he
would need a few trial runs but that it
would certainly be
no big deal for him i wonder what he
meant by that
despicable me has put smiles on the
faces of people of all ages
relatively early in the 2010 film
villain grew visits the bank of evil to
apply for loan
in small letters assigned below the
bank's name reads formerly lehman
brothers
it is a joke which adults of the
generation in particular are likely to
get
after all lehman brothers kicked off the
banking crisis in 2008 with their
insolvency
one of the most clearly ambiguous scenes
in children's films can be found in the
road to el dorado from the year 2000
shortly after julio massaged shelds back
they hit on the sofo
they were no longer visible but you
could hear more than just distinct
sucking and smacking noises
these are interrupted by a hello and
suddenly their hats reappear in two
different places
twilio's gaze looks well let's say
satisfied
all adults can surely guess what was
going on on the sofa whether the younger
audience also understood this
is a question that should better remain
unanswered
these were our 10 moments in family and
animation movies that only adults will
understand
i hope we were able to show you one or
two clips that you didn't already know
if you know of any ambiguous jokes or
scenes in children's films that you
would like to be put in a video
please post them in the comments and who
knows we might soon have an episode with
your suggestions
[Music]
you